this Prague astronomical clock may be
the most well known astronomical clock
in the world the oldest part of this
clock is from 1410 although we do have
records of clocks preceding this piece
besides a Chinese astronomical from 1088
we have very few clocks in Europe that
actually date from the mid 14th century
wallingford was a clock maker who
actually did a lot of different clocks
and he had what was considered a large
astrolabe style clock showing the Sun
the moon's age phase a node a star map
and possibly the planets an addition
actually had a Wheel of Fortune an
indicator of the state of the tide at
London Bridge and bells that rang every
hour the number of Stokes indicating the
time these clocks illustrate that one of
the many impulses and their development
had actually been the desire of
astronomers to calculate and investigate
steal phenomena so I'm basically taking
you through a brief history of these
things I'm kind of excited to get you
some more what I feel are the
exceptional parts of her ology but the
history of watches began in 16th century
Europe so this is where basically
watches develop from a portable spring
driven clock which appeared in the 15th
century now this was due to the
invention of the mainspring where I was
shaving in that tool earlier the susi
generating machine now that was actually
created in order to calibrate basically
the springs inside of these so here you
have a fusee you can actually see the
fusee let's see if you look there
there's a cone there at the bottom
that's actually what that tool that I
showed you earlier generates but in
addition yeah about the same time we
actually have time finding its way into
the church or really rather that church
found its way into time we have clocks
that regulate prayer but we also have
these pieces that were actually made to
mechanize prayer so this is a very
interesting piece this is a penitent
monk this otamatone wind wound would
actually glance left to right it would
open and close its mouth not its head is
easing at the cross each time and it
moved about 20 inches forward on a flat
surface so this is actually the act of
mechanized prayer
this piece was commissioned by King
Phillip when his son took a tumble down
some stairs and in an effort to convince
God to save his son he said God if you
grant me a miracle I will grant you one
in return and when his son healed he
commissioned the court clock maker to
actually create this penitent monk so
that he could go on running his kingdom
and have this pray piously for him I
mean can you imagine you're really busy
you're a ruler you have a lot to do just
wine this guy up you get to go
this is actually quite a long clip
so her ology though was not just used
for prayer but actually also to frighten
churchgoers into penitence this is a
16th century devil otamatone that still
resides in the applied arts collection
and serve as a castle in Milan this was
actually a groaning bobbling demon so
when a churchgoer would enter the church
this this torso would be situated so
that you know someone hidden could
actually wind this crank which would
generate this horrible groaning sound
created by organ pipes and a waggling
demon head would pop up and scare you I
mean it went past making groaning demon
heads you actually had these mechanical
grottoes and heavens and howls where
people would make pilgrimages to these
places to actually pay homage to these
things high nor pious you were the more
likely you got you were to see these
kinds of things one of these was known
as the Breton Jesus and it actually
would roll his eyes around in his head
he had blood flowing from a wound in his
side and there were women at his feet
you know just a chelating quite upset
idli while a Trinity with shifting eyes
would stare at onlookers so meanwhile
while the church is using these types of
atonement we actually have transatlantic
travel tradition transoceanic travel
growing significance in the 17th century
so obviously the importance of reliable
navigation at sea became an issue so
scientists had been working on this
problem for quite some time but in 1714
the Queen Anne act was used to try to
get people to calculate longitude at sea
so latitude was relatively easy but
longitude was not this was solved by
John Harrison who was a clock maker who
actually created this particular piece
which is h4 this is the world's first
ship chronometer that allowed us to
calculate longitude at sea reliably
[Music]